it is unbelievable where they were and
just i guess to me how quickly it all
fell apart
it really is because you know
jacksonville the saxonville defense you
could sit there and go back in 2017 you
could go they might have the best duo of
linebackers and miles jack and kelvin
smith they might have the best
cornerback duo in football and bouilla
and jaylen ramsey and they had the best
defensive line in football with dante
fowler kalayas campbell yannick and
gawkway marcel darius like holy cow it
was unbelievable and the fact that you
know they only got the one play off
appearance and it just it all fell apart
so quickly to me
i guess that's the shocking thing let
alone yeah lennon fournette allen
robinson not there some other really
talented guys but man this team was on
the brink of me going like whoa
this defense has a chance to be like one
of the more dominant defenses we've ever
seen i think i mean they were dominant
in a year in 2017 where their offense
couldn't do anything and they were still
dominating um but it just shows you how
quickly things can change in the nfl
i want to circle back to what peter said
all the draft picks the jaguars have
coming up who's going to be there to
exercise those picks that helps us
underscore the point we made last hour
peter in response to this notion that
the jaguars are somehow tanking they're
not tanking because if they tank doug
marone's gone as the coach and dave
caldwell's gone as the gm they've got no
incentive to tank if they're in their
first year maybe no they may be in their
last year and it may be someone else who
comes in next year into one of the most
attractive jobs in football with all
those draft picks
what people don't understand about
tanking
is that
all the players who are going to be
playing for the jacksonville jaguars
this year
uh
they're they're all
basically on tape for everybody in the
league right if they're half a step slow
or if they don't do anything
uh you know to stand out at all and they
go oh and 16
you think somebody else is going to hire
them next year no
tanking is the biggest myth in the nfl
timeout
time out but the tanking comes from
getting rid of all the good players of
course the players who are on the field
are going to do their absolute best the
argument for tanking is jalen ramsey's
gone yannick and gawkway's gone leonard
fernette's gone this guy's gone that
guy's gone we're down to all the scrubs
now so we're just gonna go let nature
take its course these guys are gonna try
their best they're just not very good
but how about last year when the miami
dolphins at this point of the year
september 1st last year everybody said
hey the dolphins are tanking and then
they went out and traded laramie tunsil
kenny stills and minka fitzpatrick and
then you know what happened they had a
better record than the patriots after
halloween
so i mean tanking is a bunch of crap
it's crap
and i think it that happens at the
higher level jackson organization
no you're right about that mike you're
right but chris greer did what he
thought was best for the long-term best
interests of the team you get two ones
for a left tackle who you really don't
want to pay 18 million a year to
i mean you know that's
i'm not saying it's the right decision
time will tell history will tell but
what i am saying is there certainly is
logic in what chris greer did
and
in in in miami and i don't think that
it's absolutely illogical in
jacksonville i saw the seeds of this
last year
uh when i was in training camp in
jacksonville jaylen ramsey
was an angry guy he was just he was
sullen he was unhappy you know he didn't
want to stay in jacksonville you even
knew that then
uh you know i asked him if he thought
his career if he was going to sign his
new contract in in jacksonville and he
said maybe right and and so
you know you could just tell something
was up because and and then look
you guys might not think of this as the
huge deal because obviously
getting rid of uh getting rid of yannick
and gawkway for in my opinion 60 cents
on the dollar max
if the if the vikings make the playoffs
the best they get for yannick and
gawkway is the 50th pick in the draft
you know a guy who's one of the best
young defensive lineman in football but
the
to me the one that told everything was
calais campbell
he's the ultimate team leader nfl man of
the year and they get rid of calais
campbell after a year in which pro
football focus rated him the top 3-4
defensive end in football
and they get rid of them for a five
and you know look some of these trades
are are to me
subtraction by subtraction
you know they
they're they that was not a sensible
trade for the jacksonville jaguars it
just wasn't and just like i think david
caldwell waited way too long uh
obviously to trade yannick and gawkway
because he didn't get nearly enough
compensation for such a good player one
of the reasons he didn't is because
yannick and gagwe made it clear
i would rather be
in you know coaching high school
football in topeka yeah than playing for
the jacksonville jaguars
it's it's it's odd to see
i you know the amount of star players
they've had and some of the arguments
and disgruntled you know moments that
you have seen in jacksonville to where
yeah you want a question sometimes about
just like what the hell is going on down
there you know they got to get rid of
dante fowler a little bit because of
that you mentioned jaylen ramsey you
know and then of course this and i know
that's not foolproof coleas campbell was
a model citizen and a model player uh
but yeah i mean it's just a shame that
that many talented guys on your roster
just three years ago all gone all of
that and and you know other thing is too
mike just on the last thing of the
tanking thing you know the tanking thing
is always an interesting conversation
coaches though they have a hard time
tanking too because no one gives them
the benefit of the doubt of the tanking
down the road so yeah because we're
gonna hold them to that record five
years down the line and everyone's gonna
go well you were three and 13 and he
can't go well we were tanking so they
they never give up as far as like what
peter's saying as far as the players on
film and putting their best foot forward
that way as well
it definitely happened week 17 of the
2014 season when the buccaneers pulled
half their roster when they were up by
10 points against the saints and they
lost the game and they got jameis
winston that's what they wanted that's
what they got it ultimately didn't work
out but it has happened from time to
time
it's not happening with the jaguars they
are trying to save their jobs doug
marone said it yesterday we played it
last hour i'm not going to be here if we
aren't any good this year let me just
raise this possibility because you know
it's kind of become out of sight out of
mind
when you look at tom coughlin's role
with the team 2017 2018 2019
how how much of
guys just wanting to get the hell out of
jacksonville is his fault peter
well i think you have to look at what
the nflpa said uh when they talked about
all of the grievances
that
players had against jacksonville uh
for
you know basically in the players
what the players contended that they
were forced to be in jacksonville in the
off-season to do things like rehab
injuries and things like that when
the the cba did not require them to do
that right or wrong
uh a cadre of the players there blamed
tom coughlin and so and the jaguars had
a stiff upper lip about it they didn't
talk about it
but you you'd have to ask the players on
this but i felt
that guys like jalen ramsey you know
really chafed at some of the tighter
regulations that tom coughlin installed
in jacksonville
yeah you know listen i think we could
sit here and certainly point the finger
at tom coughlin a little bit i i
understand that i think there's some
good things he did there in jacksonville
too you know hey the first year he was
there they went to the afc championship
game i think some of that was because of
you know the things he had implemented
there and and probably a a style of
practice and just a different aura
around the whole organization that
probably benefited them as a football
team but there's that fine line of going
too far and becoming too much of a
dictator and not having an ear to your
players or compassion for your players
and to me that seems like you know just
on the outside looking in what happened
and you know then it becomes yeah hey
listen
this is not the 80s and 90s anymore the
modern day athlete's a little different
yeah we got a few more jalen ramsey's in
football who you know where they're wear
their heart on their sleeve you know
when when they're emotional they let you
know and they say it and you know i
think there was a different in
difference in generations there but the
biggest thing to me too is kind of what
peter brought up
you can't be like hey we're going to be
detailed we're going to be a rule
follower you got to follow the rules got
to follow the rules while wait i'm going
to break all the rules and not follow
them but you guys gotta follow mine that
to me is where you start to fall on deaf
ears and where i think players saw that
and wait that's kind of hip hip you know
that's kind of a hypocrite there he's
gonna break rules but he expects us to
follow all his rules and uh i think
that's where it kind of fell apart for
jacksonville
you were going to say hypocritical but
you had to flash through your brain that
there's a chance just a chance that it
was going to get you a new addition to
the sims i'm always guessing things that
are coming out of my mouth yeah i know
i know but now i'm gun shy gunshots i'm
about to say the right word i'm like
wait is that right hold on
i think the fact that that they and
remember how they unceremoniously dumped
tom coughlin before the end of the year
i mean he was going to retire anyway
just let him finish out the year let him
keep some of his dignity instead of
reaching in and firing him and it it
created a real sense at first is marrone
out is caldwell out there was a report
that marone was going to be fired that
came out just before the
the week 17 game i think espn reported
that and then doubled down and tripled
down and operon wasn't fired uh there is
just kind of a weird sense of what
ownership wants in jacksonville but i
think it's smart
to give the organization a year to kind
of breathe without coughlin there as the
overlord and and maybe maybe this
dynamic of guys who can't wait to get
out of jacksonville maybe that's going
to end peter
yeah you know shot khan was very clear
at the end of last year he did take some
time to think about it i think he and
arthur blank uh you know his
his buddy up i-75 uh in jacksonville are
in in in atlanta had the same kind of
thought at the end of last year man
maybe i should clean house but both of
them said no i'm going to do do it the
steeler way i'm gonna i'm going to be
stable and so the falcons kept their
guys and and shot khan
chose to keep his guys but it was very
clear it was made very clear in
jacksonville last year that you know
look doug marone is right if he doesn't
win this year even though he's got a
hand and a half tied behind his back
he's going to get fired yeah and and you
know also let's not forget mike i know
we discussed this at the end of last
year too with doug marone you know as
far as the conversation there and just
saying
i remember him making a comment and i'm
paraphrasing a little bit but that he
couldn't do everything he wanted to do
because of some of the forces above him
and i know you and i took that as like
uh tom coughlin might have had his hand
in the cookie jar in a little too many
you know areas and everything like that
to where yeah doug marones probably
feels like like damn i've been
handcuffed as a head coach the last few
years too and how i want to run this
football team and deal with my players
and i think that's probably caused some
of the issues down there as well
i think it's one of the reasons why the
trend that kind of was starting with
bill parcells is never really going to
go anywhere whether it's mike holmgren
parcells tom coughlin i think it's very
hard for a football coach to work for a
football team and be anything other than
a football coach because that's all he's
ever done so he's going to coach the
coach if he's employed in any capacity
with the team and maybe the end result
is you just can't have those guys around
unless you hire them to be your head
coach
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports